عدد المتضررين كبير جدا يعني كما تحدث
تحدثت السلطات هنا ان اكثر من 13 مليون
شخص تضرروا في المناطق الجنوبيه وفي
الولايات العشر نتيجه هذا الزلزال
وبالتالي نعم بالفعل هناك يعني تفاهمات
وهناك تنسيق بين الحكومه وبين القطاع
الفندقي لاستقبال المتضررين في القطاع
الفندقي وايضا هناك الخيام ومراكز الايواء
لكن العدد كبير وبالتالي يتم اجلاء هؤلاء
الى مناطق اخرى مثل اسطنبول وانقره
مناطق اخرى
لاستيعاب هذه الاعداد وما زالت عمليات
الاجلاء مستمره
وبطبيعه الحال فاطمه يعني حتى وان كانت
الخيام كافيه او المنازل المؤقته كافيه
هناك ظروف اخرى تفرض نفسها على هؤلاء
المتضررين بسبب
الظروف الجويه وبسبب بروده الطقس يعني
درجه الحراره تصل الى ما دون صفر في الليل
وبالتالي هم بحاجه الى
التدفئه وبحاجه الى الاغطيه الاغطيه وهي
تحديات كبيره تواجه السلطات وتواجه ايضا
المتضررين الذين يبيتون لياليهم في هذه
الخيام